قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
ان تونس شريك مهم للاتحاد الاوروبي واعلنت
عقب لقائها الرئيسه التونسيه قيس سعيد في
تونس على راس وفد اوروبي رفيع ضم رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
اعلنت ان الاتحاد يدرس تقديم مساعده
اقتصاديه وماليه لتونس تصل الى 900 مليون
يورو و150 مليون يورو لدعم الموازنه
التونسيه بشكل فوري وكشفت المسؤوله
الاوروبيه عن اتفاقات مع الجانب التونسي
لدعم النمو الاقتصادي والاستثمار والتعاون
في مجال الطاقه المتجدده والتصدي لظاهره
الهجره غير النظاميه
واضافت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبيه سيمنح تونس 100 مليون
يورو لمكافحه الهجره غير النظاميه
بخصوصي الهجره كيلان لديه مصلحه كبيره في
كسر هذا النموذج التجاري الساخري للمهربين
انه لامر فظيع ان نرى كيف يخاطرون عمدا
بحياه البشر من اجل الربح لذلك سنعمل معا
على شراكه عملياتيه لمكافحه التهريب
وسندعم تونس في مجال اداره الحدود سيقدم
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا العام 200 مليون
يورو لتونس لاداره الحدود وكذلك لعمليات
البحث والانقاذ ومكافحه التهريب وعمليه
الاعاده
وكان رئيس تونسي قيس سعيد قال امس خلال
زياره لولايه صفاقس التي تشهد وجودا كبيرا
للاجئين قال ان بلاده لن تقبل ان تقوم
بدور الحارس لدولهم في اشاره الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي
لا نقبل بان يعامل اي شخص معامله غير
انسانيه
ونعمل على ان يكون كل من يفيد الى تونس في
وضعيه قانونيه هؤلاء ضحايا ضحايا نظاما
عالمي للاسف يتعامل معهم لا كذاوات بشريه
ولكن مجرد ارقام
ولا يمكن ايضا ان نقوم بالدور بان نكون
حراسا لدولهم
[موسيقى]